we're here in the walk gallery putting
the finishing touches on the exhibit and
you may hear some banging and clanking
in the background
those are my colleagues who are getting
things ready for the opening in just a
few hours our exhibit is called preach
and that word for us signifies the fact
that our projects are reaching out into
the community and from the very
beginning when focused on public sector
work that is projects that are
commissioned by local government state
government colleges and university
public sector schools and so forth we
feel that that's important because
everyday people taxpayers see our work
and it's our opportunity to bring design
excellence to a very broad base of
customers and users so the projects you
see here on the result of that sort of
engagement and also bringing class
abusers to the table as meaningful
design process and while I've paused in
that work process I mentioned that there
there are sketches and developmental
models it isn't simply recording what
we've done we want to give a glimpse of
how the work is done thought process
leading up to these finished buildings
we built backgrounds and supports for
models that actually lead you in and
reach through the space and provide a
certain architectural element to the
design of the exhibit itself the
question of our proudest achievement for
me is a difficult one because it's been
an evolution as our firm started this
one person than two than five and so on
each stage of our development has its
moments of pride and of significance in
our firm if I could single out the
National Museum on the mall as as a
proud moment with the caveat that is not
done yet and we're still still working
on it and it's been a tremendous process
I really enjoyed my time as a student
here
I looked at other places had other
opportunities from graduate school and I
chose MIT because when I went to the
studio I noticed two things first that
the projects were focused on the human
scale more so they weren't monumental
projects many times there were housing
projects and planning process of that
sort but also that the students were
very friendly and open the studio
environment seemed very welcoming and
those two things stuck out to me and
when I got here it really did pan out
that way where I had very successful and
energetic interaction students and
faculty and the projects I think were
ones that made difference difference in
people's lives everyday people and
really is its connection forward to our
firm as we continue to do the kind of
work that we studied here many years ago
about six years ago I started
conversations with Dean Santos and Yano
Chang Department at the time they were
interested in infusing more of a
professional perspective into the
curriculum and I was very interested in
doing the same so we had common goals
that students should have some exposure
to what it's like to build a practice
and be professional out in the real
world at the end of the day you know
design doesn't get done unless you have
a practice and a method and a process
that is profitable allows you to keep
your doors open and engage clients in a
meaningful way
you know as I came back to teach you
know the natural tendency is to make
comparisons to when you were a student
one of the things that I saw was that it
was a paucity of diversity here in the
school especially if you're talking
about African Americans that is
something that I want to work on with
the fear takes an effort getting the
diversity of getting opening up
opportunities for a broader range of
students doesn't just happen if you wait
for it to unfold that what you have to
be assertive about because was such a
small profession you know it doesn't
occur to bright young students in an
urban setting that I want to be
architect because they don't see any as
an example
the profession of architecture is only
2% African American forces so exhibits
like this help to raise the visibility
of this great thing we do call it
architecture in having someone like
myself as a role model might encourage
young people to to pursue this the
exhibition is fantastic really exciting
to have this in our schools just put
together beautiful I mean it's really
really well done a lot of people work
very hard to make this happen
I'm one of those classmates from MIT
I love the exhibit I've always watched
this work a watch Commission began to
become the quality architect that he is
the one that got commented to him
tonight was what I like about the work
of this firm is how they are able to
incorporate light and color together
study models that are made what I really
love about this kind of model is that it
there made it from such provisional
materials cardboard and little pieces of
wood and foam but what you see here is
people really thinking in three
dimensions they had been the teacher and
the professional practice class which
was really informative and really
helpful
I learned a lot and I also
a reader for my thesis which was really
great actually I'm coming who has made a
lot of buildings that are quite
successful when you look at the work you
don't have to be a pocket F to
appreciate it particularly looking at
the fact that painful trouble public
spaces so I think it reminds you that
architecture can be a way to introduce
to communities visions of success and
how public buildings can do more than
just house a program or service but